President Trump says he will announce
his decision on the Iran nuclear
agreement later today a CBS News poll
finds 21 percent of Americans want the
u.s. to remain in the deal while 21
percent want to leave but 57 percent
more than half of us say they don't know
enough to have an opinion six world
powers including the u.s. brokered the
deal in 2015 to halt Iran's nuclear
program in exchange for sanctions relief
where's Jiang is at the White House wage
a good morning good morning European
allies have desperately tried to change
president Trump's mind but they don't
believe it worked
one diplomat tells CBS News the chance
of this Agreement staying intact is
quote very small no matter where you go
in the Middle East wherever there's a
problem Iran is right there president
Trump has not provided any details about
what a US withdrawal would look like my
number-one priority is to dismantle the
disastrous deal with Iran but a pledge
to renegotiate or dismantle the deal was
one of his earliest campaign promises we
took off the sanctions and we made this
horrible deal president Trump has long
said the agreement brokered under
President Obama must also address Iran's
ballistic missile program inspections at
military sites and the sunset clause
that would allow the country to restart
some of its nuclear ambitions in 2025
negotiations in involve give-and-take
last month Iranian Foreign Minister
Javad Zarif told Margaret Brennan his
country would likely abandon the
agreement if the u.s. pulled out if the
benefits of the deal for Iran start to
diminish then there is no reason for
Iran to remain in the deed but Iranian
president Hassan rouhani has said his
country would be willing to stay if
other countries involved played by the
rules European leaders have lobbied the
president in person to uphold the Accord
British Foreign Secretary Boris Johnson
visited Washington on Monday even
appearing to reach out to the president
on Fox & Friends the president has been
right to call attention to it but you
couldn't do that without just throwing
the baby out with the bath water without
scrapping the whole thing a president
Trump had until Saturday to decide
whether to continue waiving the
sanctions at this point it seems the
question is not if but how he will
reinstate them will he simply decline to
waive the sanctions or issue new even
tougher ones gale
all right well no later today thank you
very much we Joe